cody i am sitting with you and you
have won how are you feeling oh my god i
feel like it hasn't really like sunk in
yet like i don't know i think i said it
once i was like oh my god i won tonight
it's so
weird i feel like i'm still in that like
shock of like you still you come out and
then you see everybody and then you're
you're taken out into a separate room i
i feel like it hasn't sunk in yet i
haven't even gotten talked to my i
haven't been able to talk to my family
like i don't know but it's it's it's
amazing it's amazing i can't
i can't complain too much you are the
second person
in big brother history to win
unanimously
after only the legend dan what does it
mean you become part of big brother lore
now i know it's so weird it's so weird
to hear this stuff because
i don't i don't know i guess i don't see
myself that way
maybe it hasn't like sunk in i i just
feel like i came played the game and
then i
come off and it's amazing that i won but
to hear stuff like that like
dan's the only person that won
unanimously like that's
a legend of the game and so i don't know
it's so crazy
that that aspect hasn't really sunk in
for me did you think you would win
unanimously tonight if you won
no not at all not at all i didn't think
it was going to be unanimous whether i
sat next to nicole i didn't think it was
going to be unanimous
when i was sitting next to enzo like i
was blown away i thought like the first
couple was going to be like
enzo cody cody enzo cody
enzo and then maybe like i pulled away
but
that's what i was hoping but i did not
think it was going to be 9-0
at all well i want to play you back a
clip from our interview before all this
began
let's take a look okay oh my god who is
that my hair because i think
i'm a completely different person than i
was
when i went in the first time i've aged
a little bit i've matured i've learned
way more i've dealt with way more
different experiences in my life whether
it's
business personal um i've just become a
different
person than i was the first go around
and i think it's for the better
i think i've learned a lot after playing
the game the first time
and coming back i think it's you give me
a couple weeks that i don't go home and
i think i'm going to the end and winning
the game
easy arrogant what a punk god i hate i
hate that i hate him
i hate hairstyle too i'm never doing
that to my head again
i will admit this this is working better
for you yeah thank you
but you you said you were gonna make it
to the end
and you said it was gonna be easy was it
easy you made it look easy
um this the lack of sleep i think will
say
it wasn't easy i think um like not being
able to sleep through the night was very
difficult but
it definitely was not easy i can't say
it was easy it was very tough it was a
lot of work it was working a lot of
different relationships
and the nerves of like uh oh like if i'm
talking to this person
is this information gonna leak out and
then it's gonna blow up in my face like
there's a lot of stuff that could go
wrong and i think the stress of that
is like there's no way that anybody
could say that playing this game is easy
you're like i'm just exhausted um now
uh speaking of not being able to look uh
nicole
said she couldn't even look at you for
evicting her
although it was such a blessing to have
the both of you in this final two
it almost this is horrible like to do
this to one of you guys but
nicole i'm so sorry where do you stand
with your relationship with her now
where do you guys go from here
um try to mend it because like i felt
like i couldn't look at her
like and for a completely different
reason like
i felt like i was like cutting like my
little sister
it was um the hardest thing i one of the
hardest things i've had to do in my life
not just this game like take the game
out of it um cutting her
was the most painful thing probably one
of the most painful things i've ever had
to do
it was it was so much more personal
and gay but like the personal aspect is
what really weighed on me um
i hope it doesn't affect our
relationship because we didn't have one
on 16
and this season we had an incredible
relationship we had a working
relationship we had a friendship we had
an
insane bond that was not just the game
and then were just incredible
as a duo i hope that that relationship
gets
isn't i hope that i hope that she can
forgive me because will you reach out to
her right away will you give her time
immediately i won't even give her time
and if she wants time then she'll tell
me she'll get time and then i'll give
her time
but um there's no way i'm just gonna
like let that just like
what do you say do you feel like you
want to apologize or no cause you were
just playing the game what do you say to
her
um i do apologize i i apologize to her
but it is a game
and so like the aspect of it if like if
it happened to me i know i would be very
angry
but i would i think it takes a little
bit of time i think it's definitely an
open wound and i don't know that i'm
gonna try to like
bum rush her and like try to like make
her forgive me because like i
i can't ask for forgiveness until she
like openly wants to forgive me herself
and so like i'm not gonna be like i'm so
sorry do you forgive me like you're
still mad at me like
i'll let her come to like grips with it
and i think i think she will
i think what however long it takes it
doesn't really matter for me because
that's not a friendship i want to lose
i mean did you have to do that did you
think that you still would have won
against her
um i do not i do not think i would have
won against her i think
i was going over it in my head and i was
like i think devon would have voted for
her
i think iam would have voted for her i
think kevin would have voted for her
because kevin had said something to me
and then i was like i don't know like
how other people
and like so for me i was like those are
like with enzo was like kind of up in
the air i was like i don't know
anybody leaning one way versus the other
with nicole like i had like
a little bit more of like a sure thing
that like maybe christmas would vote for
her because they had a bond
i had a lot of fun spending the last
week with you guys and you guys are both
very deserving
are you surprised that nicole voted for
you she had said to me
um even if you cut me i will vote for
you still
um so i was not that surprised but
it was actually still surprising because
the look on her face was like
like i don't i can't even look at you
like i don't know that i want to vote
for you
so like i was a little surprised i mean
you won the final hoh like you did the
first season
how important was it for you to not make
that wrong decision again when did you
know you would take
enzo over nicole um right away
i thought so much about it like that's
part of like what i was doing this
season like my head never stopped
and so i thought about this every single
day i would look at the memory wall
every day and be like how do i think
this vote's going to go how do i think
this vote's going to go
if i'm sitting here if if she wins and
takes me how is the vote going to go if
i wouldn't take her how's the vote going
to go like
i was racking through all of these
different things
and so for me like playing that out was
like you know what i think i just got to
take ends out
well you said you're going to use this
money to plan for your future
yeah does that mean maybe a little money
for an engagement ring
um we'll find we'll see i think the next
thing
her and i are looking to move in
together and so we'll find out after
that
it would be a smart move i would
recommend it yeah but
yeah i know she's i mean i feel horrible
about what i put her through with this
so
well how excited are you to reunite with
her after 85 days
i can't even i can't even express it
there's like no words for it like
i'm dying to do it i can't wait to see
her what's the first thing you want to
do other than see her any food you want
anything you want to do sushi i want it
so bad
i want sushi and wine like wine where i
don't have to like
ask and only get one glass like i want
to drink wine and so like i don't really
want it and i want to eat sushi until i
don't want to eat that anymore
so you want to get drunk eat sushi and
propose yeah we'll see
[Laughter]
it's not a bad night i think it sounds
great so you've missed a lot in the
world we want to play a little pop
culture quiz with you i'm going to ask
you things that have really happened
so we have one right answer in here see
if you can get the correct answer on
something that's really gone down in
hollywood oh my god i love this i'm
obsessed already
i'm so glad which celebrity was a
contestant on this season of dancing
with the stars was it
governor andrew cuomo tiger king star
carol
baskin or actress lindsay lohan lindsay
lohan
wrong carol baskin was like oh my god
what i know
why would they bring her on they did she
did not win
um who got engaged while you're in the
house taylor swift and her boyfriend joe
alwyn
gwen stefani and blake shelton or camila
cabello and
shawn mendes oh kabila bay and sean
mendes
i love how much you stand them but no
they are not there yet gwen and blake
are engaged oh my god
i feel like every time that was gonna be
my second answer i should just go with
that one to start
dang all right this one's a little fun a
little dirty
which superhero star accidentally
released a not safe for work pick
on the internet was it chris hemsworth
chris pratt
or chris evans chris evans
oh my god what
how did you know you're the only one to
get that right oh my god i feel like
when you ask the question i in my head i
was like it's gotta be chris evans like
i feel like chris evans did that
and then i was like done it's chris
evans you immediately thought captain
america did that yeah
yeah everybody else said chris pratt oh
that's funny
so you're the only one to get that right
great job single
so i was dating a sports nigger's
daughter so i was like uh-oh
good good thank you for something too so
good analytics would you play again
not our game but big brother yeah um
i if christy let me go back a second
time
probably not in the near future because
i definitely think that was one of the
biggest benefits
is that i had a big gap um but
if big brother called like how could i
say no they've completely changed my
life so
could you win again i have no idea
in the house we did want to ask
everybody uh you know
everything you've done has been on
camera any regrets anything you would do
differently or anything you want to say
to the fans
um i regret this disgusting habit that i
have
of like my sinuses so i regret that um
which is a little aggressive i probably
should just get that to myself and so i
apologize for that
anything you regret in the game anything
i regret i don't think so
okay um some viewers did critique
and say that not enough big moves were
made how do you feel about that agree
uh totally i agree i think that was
something that was said about 16 but the
thing is is like for me
making a big move just draws attention
and when like stuff is going your way
like
why would you draw attention to yourself
and make a big move that is just
unnecessary for your game
and so for me the big move would have
been made if somebody else
that was outside of like the power that
was had and i was one hoh and it just
didn't happen
it's unfortunate and i feel like it gets
kind of like tedious and boring
um but i mean i wouldn't change it
who do you walk away with uh staying
closest to
enzo loves you so much enzo enzo will be
like
i'll see enzo all the time because it's
like enzo i had that bond like i had
with derek
but derek lives like three and a half
four hours away so like it's not easy
just be like dude what are you doing
this weekend
like enzo i can do that with i could be
like are you coming down the shore
let's go to the beach i'm going up to
hoboken let's go meet up there
so it'll be nice to have that bond and
then i honestly i really hope nicole
and then i really really bonded with
tyler and danny all right well i gotta
wrap with you but just give me a couple
words for your emotions right now how
you're feeling how would you describe it
this feeling of being done
getting to go home and winning oh um
it's the tr that's the triple threat
it's just everything is is amazing i
think it'll hit me in a little bit
i still feel like i'm like still in like
the game like in my head still going
about like how do i answer these
questions right like it's like like how
you have to do in the house so it's like
i haven't gotten to decompress yet i
think when that sinks in
that's when all the emotions will flood
me okay well you got five hundred
thousand dollars
okay
yeah pretty great all right so excited
to hear of the news of your engagement
congratulations yeah
congratulations we have loved watching
you this season you're so awesome so
deserved everybody said you deserve to
win this one
thank you so much all alright see you
later legend